promixité vous est présenté par ngj
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
[Musique]
professionnelle bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans promixité l'émission qui
vous parle de la place des femmes dans
le monde du travail aujourd'hui focus
sur les violences contre les femmes dans
les transports qui en 2024 sont toujours
aussi préoccupantes pour preuve 43 % des
violences les plus graves dans l'espace
public franilien sont perpétrées dans
les transports en commun d'ailleurs 9
femmes sur 10 il ont déjà été victime de
violence sexiste ou sexuelle et 40 % des
passagères de la RATP ne se sentent pas
en sécurité du coup ilî-de-fance
mobilité a décidé de réagir avec le
premier lieu sécurisé du réseau il
s'agit d'un magasin relais implanté dans
la station auert où les employés ont été
formés pour recueillir rassurer et
renseigner les victimes 35 autres safe
place devrai d'ailleurs voir le jour en
2024 c'est bien mais c'est trop peu
selon les associations rappelons que la
RATP compte 302 stations de métro et 66
gares RER sans oublier bien sûr les 390
gares de la SNCF bref si on fait le
calcul ce sont moins de 5 % des gardes
d'île-de-fance qui seront dotés en 2024
de ces fameux safe place voilà prixité
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite sur public
scena
promixité vous a été présenté par NG
acteur engagé en faveur de l'égalité
professionnelle